خارج العاصمه كيشيناو حقول على مد البصر
تشكل الاراضي الزراعيه نحو 75% من اجمالي
مساحه مولدوفا لكن للمفارقه بات المزارعون
يعانون وضعا صعبا للغايه
يستغل نيكولاي برفقه ابنيه حقول الحبوب
والذره يقول انه فقد القدره على الوصول
الى اسواقه المعتاده اوكرانيا وروسيا
بسبب الحرب يتوقع افلاسه اذا استمر الوضع
على حاله
حاولنا تصدير تجاه رومانيا لكن شحناتنا
كانت مجبره على التوقف في طابور الجمارك
اسبوعا كاملا فمن المستحيل ان نصدر في مثل
هذه الظروف لذا نحن مضطرون الى تخفيض
الاسعار
يبدو ان لا احد في مولدوفا توقع ان تواجه
البلاد هذه الازمه بسبب الحرب وان تنال
قطاعا تعده المحرك الرئيس للتنميه
الحرب انعكست سلبا على مولدوفا مشاكل
لوجستيه وارتفاع جنوني في اسعار قطع
الغيار والبذور والمبيدات البنوك لم تعد
قادره على اقراض المزارعين واوكرانيا بدات
تستخدم مولدوفا منصه عبور وتسوق منتجاتها
باسعار منخفضه ما يعرض مزارعين للافلاس
تداعيات الحرب ماثله هنا ايضا في السوق
المركزي للخضر والفواكه في كيشينا
والعاصمه
ايرينا موظفه في القطاع الخاص ترتاد هذا
السوق بمعدل مره كل ثلاثه ايام تقريبا في
الاسبوع تقول انها لاحظت ان الاسعار لم
تتوقف عن الارتفاع غداه الحرب
في المنتجات لكن الدخل لا يسمح بشراء جميع
المنتجات الاساسيه الضروريه للحياه واعتقد
ان هناك زياده كبيره في الاسعار تمت فجوه
كبيره بين الدخل والنفقات
لم تعد ايرينا تنفق مثل ما كانت تفعل قبل
الحرب ولم يعد الباعه راضين ايضا عن تراجع
ايراداتهم
الاسعار ارتفعت مقارنه بالاعوام الماضيه
بسبب ارتفاع اسعار المبيدات والطاقه لدي
شعور بان اغلب الناس اصبحوا غير قادرين
على اقتناء كل ما يحتاجونه
في بلد لا تزال توازاته السياسيه
والاقتصاديه هشه يبدو ان كل شيء فيه سيظل
رهلا بالتطورات الجيو السياسيه في المنطقه
حاله انتظار وترقب تخشى الحكومه اذا
استمرت طويلا ان تسبب لها مشكلات مع
الشارع نور الدين بوزيان الجزيره كيشيناو
مولدوفا